you can always it's always the eyes
you can tell
there is something weird here going on
yeah yes and they're all focused on the
person filming shrieking screaming
middle fingers up
protect trans kids
and when I was watching this clip all I
could hear was
you see these people just lying around
on the ground pretending to be dead
totally flipping the script of what
happened
it here when I saw this clip
was give us Barabbas that's all I could
hear I I know that's not what they were
literally saying but I thought this is
the way mobs always work some people are
incredulous that the mob would behave
this way
this is what mobs do